if you were thinking of picking up
modern warfare to campaign remastered
here's what you'll get remastered by be
Knox the new campaign includes better
animation improved audio and brand-new
visuals that means up to 4k and HDR
support on console and an uncapped frame
rate and ultrawide monitor support on PC
that said you will have to wait a little
longer to play modern warfare 2 on PC
for Xbox one those versions won't
release until April 30th but the
remaster is available now on ps4 for 20
bucks in the US and UK pick that up
and you'll also get the underwater team
classic Ghost bundle that gets you the
UDT Ghost operator skin which is
inspired by the modern warfare 2 mission
the only easy day was yesterday the
bundle also includes two weapon
blueprints a weapon charm new finishing
move voice quip animated calling card
emblem and to battle pass tear skips all
of that stuff is usable in both modern
warfare and war zone you can get
immediate access to the same bundle if
you preorder modern warfare 2 campaign
remastered on Xbox one or PC even though
those versions are coming later this
remaster was something of a surprise
although there were plenty of leaks
leading up to the actual announcement
GameSpot is the best place to read up on
all of that and see more remastered
gameplay stay frosty yet
you